Joe ah silica spent almost 18 years in
the Royal Navy he served in the
Falklands conflict Northern Ireland and
the Middle East and he was awarded
medals for long service in Good Conduct
but in 1993 he had them taken away and
he was dismissed from the military
because he was gay they did a trumped up
charge against me to which I was found
not guilty but in addition they threw
another charge against me which is
conduct prejudicial to good order and I
was found guilty of that one which was
ridiculous because you can't be found
not guilty of the main charge but found
guilty of a secondary when Joe served in
the Falklands conflict there was a ban
on gay people serving in the British
Armed Forces
that was only lifted in the year 2000 so
Joe was forced to keep her sexuality
quiet for his entire career being gay
you had to hide it conceal it all the
time so you in theory was you know he
was leading a double life Joe took the
Ministry of Defence to court and one we
asked the MRD for an interview they
declined but gave us this statement back
in 1993 because of his sexuality
mr. OSA liquor was treated in a way that
would not be acceptable today and for
that we apologize we accept our policy
in respect of serving homosexuals in the
military was wrong
discriminatory and unjust to the
individuals involved Joe will be
rearwards medals next week 27 years
after he was forced out of the Navy and
a scheme will be set up to return medals
to other veterans thrown out simply
because of their sexuality
Alistair bungle Sky News